We've gotten away from using the term retard
as an insult or in casual language in modern
American society because it's not good for
people who actually suffer from down syndrome.
It's not good for their families and their
friends.
It's not good to use that term about people
with other cognitive and intellectual limitations.
But this apparently it hasn't stopped the
Iranian president from seemingly seriously
claiming that Donald Trump suffers from mental
retardation.
This was during the live televised address,
at least partially commenting on the new US
sanctions against Iran that President Donald
Trump has announced Donald Trump, of course,
imposing these new sanctions on Iran, the
Iranian President Hassan Rouhani calling the
sanctions outrageous and idiotic and adding
that quote, the White House is afflicted by
mental retardation and does not know what
to do as translated and reported by the Associated
Press.
From the native Farsi.
There are other translations that are a little
bit softer suggesting that the terms cognitive
limitations or something along those lines.
We're actually what was used a disagreement
about exactly how it should be translated
from Farsi now almost as importantly, but
maybe not quite pragmatically.
Uh, the uh, Iranian president also saying,
quote, you sanctioned the foreign minister
simultaneously with a request for talks.
And this goes to the erratic and sort of a
very strange nature of what Donald Trump has
been doing with regards to Iran that I talked
about in the first segment and w which we
discussed the undeniable reality that in the
end when you put the bluster and the rhetoric
aside, Donald Trump's actual actions are going
mostly in line with what a Vladimir Putin
with Russia as the top priority would want
Donald Trump to do.
A four years ago, I had told you that in 2019
world leaders would be calling each other
rocket man and mentally retarded.
I wouldn't have believed it.
Maybe some in our audience would.
But here we are in 2019 and there's this hilarious
double standard among Trumpists who all of
a sudden now we're pretending that mentally
retarded is outside the lines and an inappropriate
way to talk about Donald Trump when they've
spent the last almost four years calling anyone
that disagrees with them.
Uh, Cook World Politics under Obama.
Let's generate productive dialogue for the
mutual betterment of all humans on earth,
world politics under Trump, who is the biggest
retard or caulk or low energy person and truly
t to take this seriously for a second, because
it is serious, people with down syndrome often
care about others and express significant
empathy.
Donald Trump actually seems to be completely
lacking that like aside from this being meant
as an apparent insult, most people with intellectual
disabilities seem to be better people than
Donald Trump who exhibits cruelty, his bullying,
nature, greediness, complete self absorption
in every way.
And Trump, meanwhile responding that, uh,
Iran, the Iranian president's mom is gay or
something like that.
I'm kidding.
But seriously, Trump is actually unstable
enough that calling him mentally retarded
could actually trigger a war.
It could actually trigger military action.
Remember that Donald Trump, just a few days
ago, approved the strike on Iran without even
considering civilian casualties.
Later, he was told what they would be, I believe
about 150 and then he canceled the attack,
or at least he claims that's the reason why
this has the potential to completely derail
Trump.
And meanwhile, the Trump administration is
still preaching.
It has leverage around the Iran deal, which
Trump backed out of John Bolton.
Donald Trump's national security advisor,
again, is saying, all options remain on the
table with Iran if they exceed the uranium
enrichment limit that is put in place by the
2015 Iran nuclear deal.
Trump pulled us out of the deal.
The United States has no authority to enforce
that deal because Trump pulled us out of it.
You can have the discussion and we have had
it already.
By the way, you can argue there are still
other signatories to the Iran nuclear deal
that have not backed out.
Uh, the UK, Germany, our European allies,
uh, and maybe you could say they have the
leverage to enforce or demand the enforcement
of that deal.
Although the United States has made it quite
difficult for them to actually do that.
The United States has given away all credibility
and leverage to demand adhering to that deal,
given that we pulled out of it.
And it is absolutely that even on corporate
media.
Uh, some Trump flack, he's a flunkies flax,
flax or flunkies Blackie's.
Uh, I think that's going to be another, uh,
urban urban dictionary term.
Uh, Trump flunkies are being allowed to say
this, that hey, Iran still has to stick to
that deal.
That's going to be up to our allies to decide
whether they want to or can't even enforce
that after the United States has departed
from the deal.
No one in the Trump administration should
even be mentioning the requirements of the
Iran deal because we are no longer here.
Part of that deal, if you disagree with me,
let me know.
I'm on Twitter at the pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show,
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com